Barbara list is one of your guys I mean
this man you love him so how did it
happen what I think you even converse
with him is that right David don't make
me wacko but up you know every pianist I
think who studies list music you um you
love what the man could do at the piano
I mean besides reading about this
wonderful charismatic personality where
people flock to him and I mean he he
aroused such enthusiasm but it's the joy
and the passion that he had for the
instrument and I have to confess when I
was younger I kept wishing I had been
born 150 years ago so I could have gone
to viola and sat at his feet or could
have been one of those beautiful ladies
who flocked around him but um the past
three years I have been living with this
man because we started this DVD series
where I immerse myself in his letters
because this is a personality who is so
misunderstood musically as well as
personally and this was a man who was so
religious and spiritual and generous I
think people forget the generosity of
soul and even when he did these
wonderful theatrics of his he felt that
he was getting his inspiration from a
higher source it was always about going
beyond him Barbara I would actually in
always agree with you wouldn't you Marco
Rexha you know what list means to you
you love them so this is a man that
probably I'm doing a lecture at
Juilliard next Monday for our seminar on
list the title is the greatest life ever
lived 10 la 10 one year slide on light
you know some someone would say how
could he have been so great because
Toscanini the the son-in-law of Horowitz
Horowitz would always say why why don't
you play more or less the symphonic
poems you only play late prelude why
don't you do that oh I don't like this
the man
and he said why what does that have to
do with it he said oh no nobody could be
that good that no one could be that good
he was never good you know and and
Horwood said looked at him and he said
it must have been up Paul's Toscanini
said and then Horowitz said something so
perfect he says well if it was opposed
it was a good one
so this was a man of religious and
spiritual spiritual well important it
became that was it's too complex to a to
even go into the vastness of this man
everyone should study something about
him why don't you because he doesn't
write just etudes he was very inspired
by the greatest etudes of that era
called Chopin's and he then said well
I'm going to write transcendental etudes
and so Barbara's going to give you the
number one just a little overture to the
cycle of 12 the whole thing 65 minutes
maybe 7 or 8 pianists in the world could
do justice to the whole cycle and then
you're going to do number 2 in which is
a real Paganini type virtuoso a tune why
don't you try and let me you think the
number two is Paganini but I always hear
Beethoven's fifth because of that pop up
of all that theme but the first one is
really just a warm-up for the pianist at
the keyboard to the whole cycle it'll
only take one minute so we'll warm up on
but I want to tell you it'll take many
more than one minutes to play it
and
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Applause]